this is a production of Cornell
University
okay folks let's get started I got Mike
all right all refreshed right stout a
little bit all right so after that
introduction I'm gonna try to paint a
picture around the physical biological
and chemical processes in soils disa
giving you that to the basic level of
understanding and I know for some of you
this is very familiar for others maybe
not but it's interesting to see how
someone presents the information right
so I'll start with the with the physical
processes in the soil so one one perhaps
most important process physical process
in soil is the ability of the soil to
retain water go to capillarity so the
soil is like a sponge and that allows
the soil to hold not only water but to
hold the solution that holds the
minerals right the phosphorus the
potassium and all that all the minerals
so and that's really that concept of
capillarity that you have particles and
that you have water that the soil
routines within the particle is really
what allows life on earth you know that
allows for the cycling of water between
the soil and the and the atmosphere okay
so here's a list of you know some
physical properties and processes that
are important I think you're probably
familiar with all of those so I kind of
emphasized this water storage and water
movement but you don't want too much
water because you also need to have air
exchange right so especially the oxygen
needs to go into the soil but you also
need to get rid of the carbon dioxide
that comes from from respiration
otherwise you get problems actually the
I'm not sure whether people know this
but the the the biosphere project in
Arizona where they built this big dome
and they tried to have a self-sustaining
unit and and that was basically ended up
being a failure and the reason was that
they had forgotten about soil
respiration
forgotten that there's a lot of carbon
dioxide it comes out of the soil and so
they had this control dome and the
carbon dioxide level started to build up
and build up and build up and at some
point in time the people that were
living there had to had to get out so
that was a little oversight but it did
show the importance of soils right so
they didn't get the one right yeah so
okay so so in general about 50 percent
of us of the typical soil list is
mineral matter its particles roughly
okay it's kind of interesting because
when you look at soil you think that
you're looking only at the at the
mineral part but there's also water and
air and organic material right so it's
not all minerals but roughly 50% the
organic material is um you know depends
Co it can be 2 percent can be 5 percent
something like that and then the air in
the water is the one that's very dynamic
right so if it rains you get more water
being held in the soil it may all even
become saturated hun percent water in
the pores and then subsequently the more
air comes in and so that's the very
dynamic component but you know it's good
to kind of keep in mind about 50 percent
its mineral particles so a probably most
defining property of the soil of course
the soil texture you're all familiar
with that right percent sense silt and
clay or maybe course fragments like
rocks and we classify the soils so we
don't really think of this as
necessarily an important component of
soil health because it's not a dynamic
property the texture doesn't really
change but it does set the kind of the
foundation of the of the health in terms
of certain things so as for example I'm
a kind of a taller than average person
right so that gives me certain
capabilities maybe I'm a little bit
better at playing basketball and it also
gives me say some challenges like
sitting on an airplane you know
and so you have you know certain natural
capabilities that are enhanced basically
based on the genetics right so if you
think of the texture as being an
inherent genetic property if it's a clay
soil it's naturally much better at
retaining water than a sandy soil but
it's also naturally much worse
that's a transmitting water or
infiltrating water right so so there's
these things that are sort of inherently
predefined by the texture so we have to
pay attention to it for the texture
because it is sort of a defining
property that we have to interpret
everything else in relationship to all
right so if we measure say the organic
carbon content or organic matter content
over soil which soil holds more organic
matter the clay or the sand the clay
right because it could it creates these
bonds between the clay particles and the
organic matter so if you see in a soil
with an organic matter or say three
percent and it's a clay soil you say
yeah that's not so good it was a sandy
soil that's great right so you have to
interpret everything relative to do that
so which soil generally has better
aeration the sand or clay tend why is
that more large particle of pores right
which Searles MO has more most
plant-available water sand or clay
alone yeah actually that is the correct
answer that is the correct answer
all right so so it's these these
typically these ideal soils and to be
kind of in between right that the sands
are one extreme they have a lot of large
pores a lot of aeration and the Clay's
have a lot of very small pores or a lot
of water retention but they don't have
the aeration and the water transmission
and these intermediate alums the silts
are the best and that's typically what
you find also in these confluence areas
that we talked about like the Nile the
Delta and Valley the indo-gangetic plain
in North China Plain they're all those
intermediate soils so as I mention
this capillarity is in is a key property
right so the the fact during Co heat
because of cohesive and adhesive forces
you have some water
being very tightly held around the
particles and then you have this ability
of the water to be held between
particles and therefore you know hold it
against gravity and so that's really
what then allows if you have say a
matrix of particles it allows the water
to be held between these particles and
how tightly it's being held is a
function of the size of the pores right
so I won't go into details so the in
this case it's a system a soil at a
particular water content you see that
the larger pores have some air in them
smaller pores are all filled with water
so that's good you're holding water so
it's available to the plants but you you
also need some of that air because it
needs to be able to breathe alright so
you need you need both so okay so a
quick demonstration so we like to do
this and I always use this slide because
how many of you know spongebob
right everybody so I yeah for it depends
a little bit on your age so I'm Way too
old for spongebob but my children were
in the high time of Bo spongebob when it
was on TV so I watched a lot of
Spongebob it's a cartoon by the way for
those of you were not familiar with them
it still is on TV probably yeah it's
really it's a funny show but you know so
I always put this slide up because then
every time you see spongebob on TV or
maybe every time you take a take a bath
and you have a sponge you will remember
this demonstration right so so we have
here too so I have water and two sponges
right so what's the difference between
these two sponges the color okay that's
a good one yeah one yeah that's what
else yeah so this is this as large
portion this has mostly small pores
right
and so these are good you probably what
I'm gonna do you probably understand
this is nothing new to you but they make
for good demonstrations to a more
general audience right so this one I say
is like ass and they still miss like a
compacted clay right there's two
extremes and so when you put a sponge in
and everybody knows this right you
filled with water and then of course the
sponge loses a lot of the water because
it moves out of the large pores right
but then it stops after a while right so
maybe if I give it another ten seconds
or so it will basically stop losing
water so there's two forces involved
here one is grab the gravity force which
move wants to move the water out or the
sponge and then there's the retention
course is capillarity which wants to
hold on to the water right and so it's
the smaller pores that are better at
holding on to the water than the large
pores right so now this so this soil
it's really the sponge is that what we
call field capacity so this happens say
in the spring or after a major rainfall
event so it becomes very wet the water
moves through the soil out towards
groundwater or whatever and then it
holds on to a certain amount of that
water right and so this water then
becomes available for the plants
now is it a good thing that the sponge
is losing water yeah
why is a good thing so there's air in
the inn yeah exactly right because you
need the air it's also good if you say
have an aquifer down there that you know
needs to be fed and because it you know
you're drawing the water or whatever so
what are some of the bad things about
that no you lose some of the water right
and something that might be in the water
Mike nitrate or a pesticide or something
like that right so that's why we see a
lot more problems with these kind of
sandy course soils with with leaching so
this is then I'm gonna do it again but
we have the the three forms of water
right so one is what what I call then
drainage water so this is what's rapidly
being lost due to gravity okay and so
this is basically not available to the
plants at all like I said it's a good
thing the air gets into the into the
soil but that's all good then we have
secondly we have what's called the plant
available water right so if a versus a
plant growing in the soil it will slowly
draw the water out of the soil so I'm
simulating that by basically squeezing
it out right so that's the plant
available water and today we'll talk
about how we measure that right and so
it's a sponge is there any water in the
left in the sponge yeah just a little
bit of water left in the sponge right so
we call that the unavailable water
because it's there's some water in the
sponge or in the soil but it's so tell
to help so tightly but the plans can't
access it right so that's basically so
that water this plant available water
that's the most in a way most valuable
for for growing crops now here's my
other sponge okay let me empty these by
the way
so this was my compacted clay sponge
right now watch the huge amount of water
that's gonna come out of this punch when
I hold that up
oops right so why is this yeah it's all
it's all tightly held water in small
pores right so is it good I mean there's
a lot available for plant growth but
there's no aeration so the roots are
very unhappy right there's no air in
into the soil so it's it becomes
anaerobic exactly anaerobic no air
exchange no carbon dioxide being lost
very bad for growing plants right so if
you have naturally poorly drained soil
or if you have a soil that has become
compacted like this one right you can
send around you know you you see that
that clump is very low in organic matter
content it has no aggregates it only has
small pores so it will behave like this
one here okay so the ideal soil is sort
of the one that's between these two this
one is losing too much water
this one is retaining too much water
you kind of want something that's right
in in between okay so I mean it makes
for a nice little demo and I think maybe
Joey will talk about some other demos
that are useful in terms of educating
farmers or students whatever on these
basic processes right so holding
retaining water in the soil it's is
really really important process okay any
questions about that
so remember spongebob especially young
people here all right so here's
basically what we what I just tried to
demonstrate if we have a sandy soil like
the first sponge you have a lot of
whoops gravitational water I'm gonna do
it this way lot of water is being lost
which is none no longer available and
then a little bit of water is
unavailable very tightly helped and but
this is the the water that's most
important okay but that's for a sandy
soil for a dense clay
the second sponge very little
gravitational water in our case
basically none more plant-available
water but also a lot of water that's
unavailable it's so tightly held in
small pores it's not available so the
ideal situation is where you have
something in between so a good you know
loam soil is you know some gravitational
water so the air can get in right some
unavailable water okay tightly helped
but you have a lot of plant available
water right and so that's why those type
of soils are the most desirable if you
look at agricultural soils most of them
are loam silt loams silts you know the
vast majority of the good agricultural
land is that sometimes maybe allow me
scent or something like that but most of
them are these intermediate soils so
what you want then is in a soil is to
have some small pores for water
retention some very large pores that the
air can get in and exchange and then
some intermediate pores right so how do
you get that well by having aggregates
so instead of having individual
particles you have our aggregates of
particles and a typical aggregate
actually has a certain certain hierarchy
in it so here's one crumb an aggregate
crumb right maybe what you see here like
one of these maybe okay
that's one crumb and then if you were to
take that apart you'll find that it has
is made up of other smaller aggregates
and those smaller aggregates are made up
of yet smaller aggregates right but it
gives you then that nice range of pore
sizes large ones for the aeration and a
motor transmission small ones for the
retention and a lot of the biological
processes tend to happen in this
intermediate pores okay and so in a way
the aggregates forms that skeleton that
allows for all these processes to occur
the water air exchange in a biological
function so and one thing that I want
you to kind of think about so when you
look at soil right at the one that's
going around or whatever you see those
minerals and what you don't see is the
porsche between the minerals but the
pores are really where all the action is
right and so a nice analogy that I'd
like to use is a building I'd say let's
take this building and you have a
skeleton and we're in a room here right
the room is supported by this building
structure the skeleton the most
important and most interesting thing
that's happening in this room is not
that structure it's us
we are the biology in this room right
we're exchanging if we were in sauna we
would be eating each other by the way I
don't want to do that we're just eating
the food but you know we'd be fighting
each other and eating each other
expressing each other but it's the
biology that's really important so so
think of it as the soil the minerals is
being house or a building and at the
interesting processes the microbes the
fungi duh you know what other other
animals I'll talk about that the action
is really happening in the in the pores
right and when we when we develop soil
and we till it we're basically
destroying the structure we're
collapsing the structure right so just
imagine that the ceiling would be coming
down to here I'd be a lot less happy if
that were the case right and most of you
probably - all right so so that's what
happening when we till the soil we lose
the organic matter that's important for
creating these aggregates and then the
surface becomes more compacted we often
do more till it's infiltration degrees
we get erosion we lose more than organic
matter that's so important for the
aggregates and so we basically have this
overall decline and then we refer to
that sometimes there's still it's
addiction because the only way to kind
of overcome this collapse is to kind of
fluff it back up again but you basically
are in a vicious cycle
all right so tillage is very damaging
any questions let's talk a little bit
about Sorel strengthen and compaction so
you know we need these aggregates to
have a relatively loose soil or a low
bulk density because it facilitates all
these physical processes like
infiltration water transmission and when
we don't have that we lose that like
that clump that you see there we start
to have runoff so a lot of the areas
that were initially developed for
agriculture that were not in these
confluence areas that were you know
maybe pasture land that was that was
being put in crop production this is
what happened and once you have that
once you start to get denser soil harder
soil the plants don't grow as well
you get erosion and runoff and then it
makes it worse so a lot of land for
example in the Middle East was a became
abandoned after a few decades so you go
now to places like southern Europe Italy
or Greece or turkey or places like that
and the soils are very degraded right
because they they became very eroded and
and it was a huge problem ok this is
what it looks like from the top you can
imagine when you have crusts like that
that you know you don't get a lot of
vegetation you see plants are having a
hard time growing right and so so and
this then interacts with the potential
for erosion let me try to explain that
so when you have soil particles and the
soil is saturated with water
it's a soil soft or hard soft right so
if you have a very wet soil you can just
push your finger into it if that soil
dries out what happens it becomes much
harder right and sometimes when it
becomes extremely dry it becomes loose
right so if you go to the beach and you
stand right by the water's edge you can
wiggle your your your feet and your toes
and you can this really soft you step
back and then the soil becomes very hard
the beach very hard like
they tone a beach if you've ever been
there and then when you again you're
further back what is it what is that the
beats look like it's just loose sand
right so where do you see the soil
moving at the waters
the water moves us moves to send
particles right back and forth right and
that's basically this scenario which is
basically water erosion on the other
side other end of the beach the soil is
loose you're sitting there eating your
sandwich and then the wind blows you're
eating sand right so it's on these
extremes and when you have a lack of
aggregates it's on the extremes where
you have the problems that's where winds
too wet you get the wind the water
erosion winds right so this is
interaction between the weather and the
stat the status of the soil and if you
have good aggregates you really minimize
those impacts I'm gonna skip that one
and that one too all right maybe that
one too sorry because I'm looking at the
at the clock a little bit so another
component so we're looking at the
sponges and you know how much water does
bunch can hold and so we say okay that's
great it you know you have that plant
available water but is it really planned
available there's something else that's
that that's a factor in that and that's
the roots need to be able to access the
water right so you can have a sponge
like this or a soil like this and it has
water in it but if the roots can't grow
into it right they can't access it so
you need both a soil that can retain the
water you need to have a soil that
allows the roots to grow and again
what's the best way to do that for the
structure to be well aggregated okay
because if you have aggregates you have
large pores the roots can get into the
large pores they can push the aggregates
to the side and you get much better
routing and much better uptake right of
water and nutrients so if you have a
very compacted soil you see there's one
root that went into the soil it may be
found the zone of weakness but most of
the soil is basically the water and
nutrients are not accessed by the roots
right so it's there
but it's not of any use to the plan just
a little bit here
Vermont avoid so this is what you want
right so you want a combination of good
water retention capacity which you'll
see how we measure that in lab and good
aggregation what the routes can access
it you see how we measure that in the
lab as well okay so here's an example of
this very compacted soil like the one
that's going around and no large pores
the roots can grow into it maybe when
the soil is very wet it's a little
softer maybe a little bit of growth but
this is you know you can see here
healthy soil is he an earthworm you see
holes there channels
you see casts and all that and the roots
will grow very well into that okay so
it's not only whether the soil can hold
the water but is it also accessible to
the plants okay so I want to move on to
the biological component any questions
about this yes there are methodologies
that are that sort of take the best of
both worlds and one that's notable is we
call strip toilets where you where you
do only a little bit of disturbance in
writing the row where the seed goes and
and the rest is undisturbed it works
well with row crop systems so that's
that's kind of the the best compromise
because you know one of the challenges
with you know if you've in intensively
tilled the soil for decades it has
become addicted to tillage
it became so compacted that each time
need to fluff it back up and so if you
didn't go what we call cold turkey into
into no-till it's going to be a disaster
because the soil is so compact
so strip till is away where you say okay
we're doing a little bit of tillage but
we didn't minimize the disturbance and
that seems to be a good way especially
for soils that are naturally challenging
for no-till for example in colder
climates more clay heavy textured soils
they have a lot more challenges both
density yes so in a way both density
you're correct is a measurement of the
aggregation right of how what what the
pore space is but absolutely correct
yeah yeah we'll talk about some of the
the way we measure it later and lob
density there's an interesting story
around that so yeah good point
all right so let's talk about the
biological component then okay so why is
the soil organic matter so important so
it's only a relatively small fraction
maybe two to five percent typically of
the soil but it's it's such an important
fraction because it basically sustains
the whole biological system so in the
book building soils for better crops did
you get it guys get a chance to look at
that I think it was a reading assignment
so we use three fractions basically of
the organic matter and the living the
dead and the very dead it's kind of a
funny way of expressing it but it
explains quite well what's really going
on so each of them are important right
and we'll try to explain that
the living is what it says living the
stuff that's alive right so all kinds of
organisms it's a it's a very rich I mean
soils are so rich in biological
materials so bacteria fungi nematodes
earthworms mite springtails moles etc
and plant roots plant which are also
alive and they're all in the soil and
and this is only a small part of it and
what are the roles well they basically
make nutrients available they acquire
nutrients they suppress diseases to help
aggregate the soils so they basically
make the soil a biologically
well-functioning system okay and it's a
just a very diverse group their roots
are so we would sorted the plant
component and they have a lot of benefit
so anytime you have a root in the soil
it has basically benefits right it
creates for space it pumps carbon into
the soil you know sometimes very deep
into the soil it exudes servers that
stimulate the food chain activity so it
basically feeds some a lot of these
organisms in the soil and maybe even a
little chemical so maybe help suppress
say weeds or other organisms so roots
are are basically a big source of the
carbon that goes into the soil and this
is an interesting how many of you have
seen this this picture all right it's an
interesting picture from the land
Institute it shows you a perennial wheat
grass that is a prairie grass and it
shows you annual wheat right so and then
it's you know of during a year time
period joke so quarterly so September
December March June so you see here how
deep the rooting system is of the wheat
grass even though you don't see a lot
above ground it has a lot of carbon
actually below ground and there's a lot
of turnover of those foods as well so it
it just released
a lot of carbon organic matter this is
the annual wheat so was planted in
September so you don't actually see any
roots there and then this is December
have a few roots then it goes to the
winter
yeah it grows some more woods and then
this is around harvest time but you see
that the dramatic difference between an
annual grass which is wheat in this case
and a perennial grass so there's just a
lot more carbon and nutrients that are
being recycled or cycled in in a
perennial system and that's why some of
these soils naturally were so so healthy
and so productive and fertile okay so
that's the living part so it's it's
these organisms earthworms mites and all
that as well as plant roots being living
so now we're gonna look at the dead so
the dead organic matter the way you need
to look at it is is is as such a food
source for all these life organisms
right so it may be fresh manure that may
be crop residue that's being decomposed
and especially the the recently dead
material so for us you know when you see
something like this this is you know for
many organisms this is its time it's
like you know we're gonna be eating some
great stuff now this is this is like a
juicy hamburger to many organisms in the
soil right this is a lot of carbon a lot
of nutrients to them that helps them
sustain right so this fresh organic
matter basically feeds the biology of
the soil so we call it the soil food web
so the ultimate source of the energy is
the Sun captured through photosynthesis
by plants it may go through an animal
may be eaten by say a buffalo or or or a
cow or whatever but it gets deposited
either the plants die off or movement or
and then that feeds the whole system
where some organisms basically decompose
the organic matter say bacteria involved
but the protozoa eat the bacteria
they release some of the nitrogen the
nematodes may eat protozoa I mean it's a
jungle down there right I mean but this
basically sustains that whole system and
if you don't have enough organic
material going into the system like I
was explaining in my previous lecture
then you diminish all the life in the
soil that makes it less viable good so
that was the so we did the living the
dead and the very dead is basically the
sort of the material that remains after
decomposition tends to be the lignin the
organic material that's very difficult
to decompose or char chari is also very
difficult to decompose it still is very
important because that's basically adds
to the ability of the soil to hold on to
water and nutrients so if you have say
especially with a sandy soil doesn't
have any natural capacity to hold water
and nutrients but if you have organic
matter in the soil then it does okay it
provides cation exchange capacity it
through chelation it can hold these
these nutrients it also holds to the
mineral interaction between mineral and
organic matter it's what allows the
soils to hold on to the organic matter
okay so if soil can hold on to a certain
amount of organic matter a clay soil
more than a sandy soil what clay sort of
hold tongue can hold on to more organic
better than a sandy soil because of the
organ Omen role bonds very important
topic these days because people talk
about carbon farming and taking carbon
out of the atmosphere into the soil so
that's that ability to sort of to do
that it's very important okay so that's
what this is I kind of got ahead of
myself
so these strong bonds between organic
matter and especially clay and fine silt
is really it's like the capillarity with
the water the ability to throw the hold
onto water and the ability of
soil to hold onto carbon is really very
important in terms of the broader
ecosystem services carbon is also very
well held within this very small
aggregates because it's basically
physically protected the organisms can't
get to it
right also very important that's why the
Clay's are much better at storing carbon
and then recently been a lot of interest
in char because it's so stable in the
soil so if you char it and put it in so
it's kind of stays around for several
hundred years not saying that that's the
solution - some people think it's a
solution to the carbon problem but it's
it's an interesting idea so the amounts
force depends on the balance of the
gains in the losses so the syllable will
store what carbon but if you say til it
you lose a lot of carbon or if you have
erosion you lose a lot of carbon right
so ideally you have more carbon going
into the soil than you then it loses but
there's a limit it has a limited
capacity to store carbon the same way it
has a limited capacity to store water
okay most of our soils have a good
opportunity to store more carbon so
that's why there's an interesting Carbon
Farming and Joseph did some analysis
that I'll show you tomorrow ok quickly
I'm going to go to a number of
biological processes that are that are
important sort of just kind of touch up
touch upon them so one of them is is
residue breakdown and an incorporation
so we have this this dead organic matter
so it may be residues it may be manure
you know there's basically fresher
organic material roots and then all
these a number of these organisms are
basically going getting to work once you
have some of these organic matter being
deposited you get the shredders out
there you get the the barriers out there
to bring it in like earthworms you get
the guys who ingested earthworms do
actually both they actually ingest the
organic material and then it comes out
as
asked through egestion they coat and
inoculate aggregates they support all
kinds of enzymatic reactions that
basically allows for the decomposition
right so just a picture so here's a dung
beetle for example so the dung beetle
loves done of the manure and a very
important process you know so so these
are great little workers that basically
support these ecosystem processes
earthworms of course who was the one who
studied earthworms very early on anybody
remember that what famous scientists
Darwin Charles Darwin at the end of his
career even though he was already so
accomplished in his early work he
decided to study earthworms were you
fascinating so they're they're basically
great great organisms they they make
holes in the soil which is very good
they create these very stable casts that
are basically great aggregates see here
you see there it helps mix the soil
increases infiltration and and helps
provide channels for roots especially if
the soil is compacted so these are
really great you can have too many of
them that's the problem here in the
Northeast where the invasive species the
night crawlers are basically taking all
the leaf litter and crossing some
problems in the forest but in most cases
they're really great organisms these are
some of the organisms that do the
shredding and and the herbivore II and
basically kind of take this organic
matter maybe leaves it maybe dead plants
and maybe nor manure and they basically
make it more available for decomposition
okay so also great guys out there
nematodes are little worms one of the
things they tend to have a bad
reputation because sometimes they attack
plants and then they cost diseases but
most limited nematodes are basically
good guys okay they're part of this food
web and
and so there they have very important
ecosystem services there's a whole
discipline you know people who are
specialists and nematodes it's just a
lot of variety so basically the idea is
and and you know our early soil health
were involved also a colleague Georgia
Bowie was a plant pathologist in in the
idea that if you have a healthy soil
with lots of healthy organisms that have
creates kind of suppressive environment
right it's kind of like the natural
system if you go to places like Kenya
and you go to the natural savanna area
you know everybody eats everybody else
even but everybody keeps everybody else
in check - so you know that there's no
organism that starts to dominate right
and you need to save in a soil if the
soil is not healthy and there's not a
suppressive biology a pathogen can
really take over right and you need to
have other organisms that keep that
pathogen in check it may be there but it
needs to be kept in check right and it's
the same like we have with humans in
society we kind of keep each other in
there's a certain amount of checks and
balances all right
so somebody's biocontrol making it so
Pythium is a serious soil borne disease
but trichoderma so Pythium is a is a
fungus Trichoderma is oh my soul
something it's like a lot of fungus like
it's something different and and and
they can basically suppress the Pythium
and there's probably hundreds of other
examples of where one organism keeps the
other one in check and I'm not
admittedly not the ultimate expert in
that but it's in very what we do see is
that when we have healthy soils we just
have less outbreak of diseases so that
brings us to the disease triangle which
is a very important concept in in
pathology so one is you need to have the
pathogen present right so if you have
say Pythium as a I saw born in a disease
you need to create also an environment
where this pathogen will thrive and so
with say Pythium it's having less
suppressive you know having less of
other organisms that basically suppress
it but also if the soil is very wet and
poorly drained it tends to thrive right
so if you have a degraded soil it
becomes very compacted like this and it
becomes wet and a disease organism will
do much better in that okay so that yes
I mean the same issue applies to you yes
I mean when we think about passages in
human pathogens in soils it probably
never really given that a lot of thought
but we do introduce a lot of human
pathogens in soil as well right right
yeah that's correct and and so if you
have a a soil environment that's not
suppressive over those human pathogens
it would be the same thing that's
correct yeah yeah good point I hadn't
thought of that
so so it's the the presence of the
pathogen the environment that may be
created by the interaction of the soil
say aggregation and climate and then of
course the host you know are you growing
a crop that is susceptible to a pathogen
for example beans are susceptible to a
lot of pathogens and you'll you'll see
that later when we are in a lab but say
corn maybe not so susceptible to some of
these so that's really but the the idea
is you know you can manage what you grow
right and you can manage the environment
by say creating a very healthy soil and
that way you can also - the pathogen
okay so good rotations maintaining good
soil structure
maintaining a lot of biological
diversity allows you to suppress these
pathogens and in many cases reduce the
interventions spraying pesticides or
things like that okay so another
important biological process is
basically making nutrients available
right so nutrients in the soil primarily
are inorganic matter unless you apply it
as a fertilizer
and then these basically are being
transformed and then the nutrients are
being made available but it's nitrogen
or phosphorus or whatever and that
process is called mineralization but you
can also have a process that's called
immobilization where the nutrients are
being drawn into the organic matter okay
so that's another important process
biological knives that's another one
absolutely absolutely yeah I think
that's in another slide yeah
okay so functional redundancy so these
are important processes but having a
rich biological environment provides
that functional redundancy which makes
it more robust and resilient so
aggregation I already kind of talked
about that and another very important
biological process so if you don't have
a by a strong biological system you
don't have a good physical environment
either because you don't get the
aggregations either through the roots or
through the earthworms or organisms like
that plant growth promotion it's a
fairly new area or basically for example
rise of bacteria that help promote plant
growth you know so the plants and the
other organisms in the soil weathers
bacteria or fungi or whatever they tend
to interact in a positive way certainly
in a healthy soil environment and also
tends to be very important for inducing
resistance to especially diseases
and then the other component is that
when we have a better aggregated soil we
also protect the carbon much better okay
because the we allow the carbon to get
into the aggregates and being protected
there right and so if we build healthier
soils we find that we can build up the
carbon levels in the soil and then we
can protect that carbon much better all
right so here's just a picture so some
of the mycorrhizal fungi hyphy the
protection of the carbon in the micro
aggregates and things like that okay all
right so I'm not gonna talk much about
the chemical process in the soil because
that's most of you I think are more
familiar with that so it's the
availability of phosphorus potassium the
pH CEC things like that
what so nutrient deficiencies but also
acidity and alkalinity very important
you know Flow pH is a real problem due
to high pH typically less but also
problem fight or toxicity where you may
have say high lead levels or cadmium
levels or something like that in the
soil especially in urban environments
are there you go human contaminants
salinity solicit II so this you know so
this Lea creates a lot of problems with
very compacted soils and things like
that so what's maybe kind of ties the
the chemical with the physical and
biological is that the the nutrients may
be in the soil but it's still they still
need to get from the soil to the plant
right it's the same with the water like
I said you the soil may hold water but
the roots they maybe need to be
accessing it so it's the same thing with
the chemistry so if you do a soil
analysis traditional soil analysis and
you measure the phosphorus potassium
content and the P eighths and all that
it may be in the soil but can it be
effectively used by the plan
well for that you need to have good
aggregation need to have roots grow and
be able to access those nutrients you
need to have diffusion and mass flow of
solution from the soil with the
nutrients like I said the roots need to
be able to proliferate there needs to be
good transport of the nutrients into the
plant you maybe need to have some help
like for example mycorrhizal fungi help
with the acquisition of phosphorus in
the soil and make in the roots in a way
that make the roots more effective so
the point here is that yes we know how
to measure phosphorus potassium
magnesium and all that all right but
that's not the entire story it also
needs to be accessible to the plants
through these biological and physical
processes right so again it's not only
about the chemistry it's about all three
of those physics physics biology and
chemistry alright and these my last
slide because I just want to I don't
know whether some of you work more in
urban environments or not but we tend to
focus on agricultural soils but urban
soils are also important for a couple of
reasons one is that most people who live
in an urban environment and increasingly
salt alright and Searles in urban
environments are also important right
when you see a tree maybe you know go
drive ten miles out of town you see a
tree so that's nice tree right if you go
to the Upper East Side in New York you
see nice tree that's really is worth a
lot more than the tree that's you know
in Lansing you know near my house so the
the natural environment which includes
the soil is more valuable in urban
environments right because more people
get to enjoy it and you know we've had
we've had many many urban areas where
the environment basically has been
destroyed and a lot of people live in
really suboptimal environments and
there's a lot of
in injustice and and and an inequity
around that but these are some of the
problems that you see in urban soils I
mean that look what it looks like so
very high bulk density very dense soil
no aggregation typically very low
organic matter very poor structure a lot
of times very high pH why is that it's a
lot of concrete in in urban areas low
water holding capacity very hard soil no
aggregate stability the roots can grow
it your typical urban tree lives in a
terrible environment right very
compacted often you know very small area
so and then you know typically microbial
biomass an activity very diminished not
only maybe because of the pH a lot of
times there's contaminants in the soil
in urban areas so we really need to you
know when we think about soil health we
tend to have this natural affinity
towards agricultural soils may be some
natural soils but in the urban
environments even though there's much
less soil it's so important because of
the high populations okay and that was
my last slide I think we did okay didn't
we Joe for you this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu